how do been for you so far cold I'm
excited to eat though I'm really
hungry and when you prepare for how much
time do you how much research do you
do well you know it really depends upon
how much time I'm given a lot of times I
don't have much time um and also cuz I'm
a mother but um you know different roles
I spend it depends on what I'm supposed
to be doing you know like I spend like 4
days
learning how to be a real estate agent
for this little movie I did called the
convincer that was at Sundance and you
know it just depends on how much I have
but I like to do a
lot yes I do most mostly they
automatically cast me but I will
audition if I really want something I
audition for I just did uh Jay Edgar
with Clint
Eastwood I audition for that okay do you
think separates you all the other
millions of actors
struggling want to be exactly where you
are what do you think you've done to get
to
this well by now after what 28 years I'm
kind of I mean I'm so famous for Back to
the Future that I'm kind of become like
I don't know almost everybody's seen
that movie so that's what's different
about me I'm lorine
mcai what are your PL for
Monday for for Monday relax Monday
yeah uh I'm not working on Monday so I'm
going to be taking my daughter to
auditions she's acting now
yeah thank
you